I like this question do you try to dress
more like a designer at work to
differentiate yourself those are two
completely different things so whilst
design itself is around creating
beautiful products and services designs
thinking is an approach to problem
finding and problem solving for me
design has always been a combination of
art and science creativity and execution
both come in harmony to be able to
innovate Design Thinking is really a
methodology or a mindset to really help
organizations upskill that creativity
side design and design thinking is
really the journey and then also the
manifestation of those meeting points
between people in the world about them
everything better makes the better
solution to the user is design without a
doubt that would be but design is the
user interface of a solution
it's a misperception in that how we got
to that user interface is really the
design we still often fight with the
understanding that design is a lot more
than just you know like a painter or a
decorator of something and most people
don't kind of understand that design
really has the capacity to really
transform by a better understanding who
your client is still fighting for having
the designer to be at the table or
strategic conversations speak multiple
languages speaking the language of
Technology the language of revenue the
language of human centered design they
are able to bring a level of rigor to
the discussion on design empathy
business acumen and also technical
acumen being a bit rebellious the
dynamics between people in the workplace
when there's conflict between people
being able to sort of scale my teams one
of the things that keeps me up at night
there's actually more design work than
designers this one's funny
I say that I had to work very very hard
in my career to dress however
I often put on a three-piece suit to
differentiate myself I'm a British boy
born and bred lots and lots of fancy
shoes quite honestly the reason I wear
black all the time is because I am
constantly spilling food down the front
of my shirt the real secret is I'm
sloppy but we can call it being a
designer as well the pace of work that's
being done is is a lot faster than an
in-house design team the opportunity to
meet many different kinds of people for
me is one of the best ways to practice
design at scale you need to really kind
of understand what you're trying to
achieve as an overall organization and
be comfortable with that
sleep whenever you get a chance right
always be able to take a nap I actually
have a meditation practice so I'm always
taking time to rest
no one is excited to have a rubbish idea
after 4 hours of sleep so I have
averaged nine hours of sleep the last
decade